sechs monate krieg in der ukraine und
auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische lage im land ansehen und
uns ansehen mit welchen waffen denn
beide seiten versuchen hier einen
vorteil zu erlangen und wir haben in den
letzten tagen immer wieder gesagt die
russen haben sehr alte waffen die
ukrainer setzten auf hightech das stimmt
an sich aber es gibt eben auch ganz klar
zu weit gehört auch fälle wo es genau
andersrum ist ja mein neues video der
ukrainischen armee disco gestern
veröffentlicht hier sehen wir eine
artillerie die mit einer jahr mit einem
seil hier sozusagen ferngezündet werden
da zieht jemand dran und dann schießt
die und diese artillerie heißt die 44
und die 44 steht tatsächlich für das
jahr in der sie entwickelt wurde
1944 die ukraine schießen hier mit
artillerie die von der sowjetunion noch
während des zweiten weltkrieges gebaut
wurde und ab februar 1945 also auch noch
vor ende des zweiten weltkrieges in
massenproduktion gehen in der
sowjetunion diese geschützte müssen die
ukraine nutzen um ihre gesamte front von
mehr als 1000 kilometer zu verteidigen
beinahe 80 jahre alte geschütze mit
dieser also versuchen hier die russische
armee zurückzuhalten das ist auch teil
der wahrheit neben all den deutschen
panzerhaubitze 2000 amerikanischen
geschützen die allerdings in viel zu
kleinen umfang alles in einem unter 200
hier bislang geliefert wurden auf der
anderen seite sagen wir seit tagen die
russen ja die nehmen halt vieles
observierten nun das ist richtig aber
die russen nutzen auch extremst moderne
drohen und wir können uns das mal
angucken das sieht erstmal aus dem ganz
normale drohnen aufnahme wir sehen ja
einen checkpoint in person die der
überwacht wird von einer drohne von oben
wir sehen auch hier das können wir genau
angucken wie sich ein auto diesen check
point nähert also ein ziviles auto was
ich einen jackpot und wir sehen aber
jetzt plötzlich gleich wie die drohne
nicht mehr heraus geht sondern wie sie
ihre richtung ändert sie geht hinein sie
bewegt sich auf diesen kontrollfunktion
und was wir hier sehen sind tatsächlich
die aufnahmen einer kamikaze drohne der
russischen armee die eben und der 10 die
sekunden vor dem einschlag extreme
modernen ist 2009/10 erster dienst
gestellt wurde ihr eigenes ziel erst
überwachen kann indem sie darüber
schwebt und dann das ziel angreift und
wir sehen es nochmal dieses ziel an wir
haben wir also diesen militärstützpunkt
und hier auch einen soldaten der ukraine
hier haben wir aber zivil fahrzeuge die
gerade überprüft werden das ganze stört
die russische armee nicht sie greift
diesen check point an obwohl zivilisten
sich darauf halten wir sehen jetzt den
einschlag und wir sehen jetzt eine
weitere perspektive hier unten sehen wir
den checkpoint und gleich sehen wir wie
sich die drohne aus norden kommt darauf
zu bewegt ob es jetzt halt mir das ganze
muss man hier ist die drohne die
kamikaze drohnen und die selbstmord
drohen hier ist der checkpoint und wir
lassen das ganze video mal weiter laufen
und sehen wie diese drohne jetzt im
checkpoint einschlägt das also modernste
russische militär technologie hier
eingesetzt wird die es zwei oder drei
jahre alt ist und eben in der ukraine
zum zum einsatz kommt gestern haben wir
gesagt dass die ukraine versucht für
ihre gegenoffensive in carson die
brücken über den den er projekte näher
präzisiert große fluss hier der das
besetzte gebiet teilt zu zerstören wir
haben jetzt aufnahmen wie diese brücke
danach aussieht also nach diesem angriff
von vorgestern nacht das sind russische
natürlich propaganda aufnahmen wo man
noch mal sieht hier sind neue löcher in
dieser brücke drin russische soldaten
sehen sich das ganze an wir haben ja
auch verschiedene kann das einem hinten
zeigen verschiedene maschinen die
versuchen diese löcher wieder zu stopfen
weil die russen natürlich unbedingt über
diesen flüssen müssen wir müssen über
den die nerven ihre einheiten ihre armee
einheiten nördlich davon zu verstärken
mit panzern mit artillerie mit munition
usw aber wir sehen eben wie diese diese
frisch gerissenen löcher hier sind die
sind relativ klein war das ist eine sehr
mächtige brücke und trotzdem sehen wir
wie die ukraine immer wieder diese
brücke beschießt mit den highlights aus
den usa mit bis zu 80 kilometer
reichweite und versucht eben diese
brücke im laufe der zeit immer mehr ins
wackeln zu bringen ins wanken zu bringen
und auch irgendwann zu zerstören die
russen während sich dagegen so gut wie
sie können ja indem sie das mit
ukrainischer technik natürlich mit
ukrainischen arbeiter immer wieder
zwangsweise hier ausbessern hat setzt
das wollen wir uns ansehen
neue waffen die in der ukraine
eingetroffen sind und wir reden oft über
die türkei als jemand der der irgendwie
dazwischen ist präsident erdogan hat
sich gerade letztens wieder mit
präsident putin ins hoche getroffen man
weiß nicht genau was für ein spieler
spielt auf der anderen seite ist das im
erdogan der der ukraine dutzende moderne
kampfdrohnen als einziges nato land zur
verfügung gestellt hat und wir haben
hier neue aufnahmen von
darauf haben vom typ ii das ist eines
der meist benutzten fahrzeuge der
türkischen armee hier in der ukraine 50
stück sollen davon gestern angekommen
seien in der ukraine
weitere 150 für die türkei liefern das
heißt die türkei ging irgendwie zwischen
den stühlen steht die irgendwie versucht
als einziges land nicht russland zu
sanktionieren und nato land und
weiterhin positive beziehungen zu
russland haben möchte diese türkei
unterstützt die ukraine mit
150 gepanzerten fahrzeugen in mit denen
sie ihre soldaten sicher von a nach b
bewegen kann insofern ein ganz
kompliziertes gebilde und ein ganz
interessantes doppelte spiel was auch
präsident erdogan spielt
[Musik]